[Música]
atualmente se fala muito sobre
algoritmos
afinal eles estão à nossa volta em todo
lugar
google facebook spotify e netflix eles
recomendam coisas para vocês todos os
dias eu sou um programador eu aprendi a
programar muito novo e aprendi a simular
e emular a inteligência humana através
de software para que ela executasse
tarefas através disso o que vem trazer
para vocês hoje aqui é desconstruir o
conceito de um algoritmo mostrar pra
vocês o que está por trás como ele é
construído porque afinal de contas se de
alguma forma ele nos entrega conteúdo
a gente precisa entender o que está por
trás disso mas vou poder explicar para
vocês o conceito de algoritmo explicar
como funciona esse é um passo a trás e
lembrar pra vocês como é que a gente
recebia a informação até pouco tempo
atrás nós tínhamos uma verdadeira parede
entre o alto escalão de empresas os
governos e toda a sociedade
a informação estava sempre no topo da
pirâmide eo resto da sociedade receber
informação via mídias tradicionais
jornais revistas que obviamente alguém
escolheria o que ia virar notícia
então aconteceu uma revolução que foi
entrar na internet nessa história e que
ela fez
ela na verdade gerou uma verdadeira
inclusão social com relação à informação
porque quer porque inclusão social
porque já que um dos principais pontos
de inclusão social é a informação o que
a internet fez foi inundar o mundo todo
mundo recebe a informação ao mesmo tempo
as informações chegam num momento que
chega no alto escalão também chegam em
qualquer parte da sociedade
isso se a gente olhar ea gente parar
para pensar um pouquinho e pensar como é
que a gente receba a informação até
agora primeiro através de papel aí a
mídia através de tv tele jornais até que
a internet entrou na história
quando entro na internet aconteceu um
pequeno problema muitos dados
ou seja big data volume absurdo
velocidade dos seus dados informados que
a gente nem tem condições de observar a
final tem gente que possa um vídeo que
dura seis segundos morre para sempre né
só que isso também nos trouxe um segundo
problema como a sociedade afinal de
contas se eu receber todas as
informações que eu tenho é que tem
disponível em toda a internet que vai
acontecer
o caos né afinal de contas o caos a
gente está muito próximo do local já que
não tem mais como fazer esses filtros e
foi aí então que surgiram os algoritmos
os algoritmos de todas as os
fornecedores que vou contar pra vocês
google o spotify e netflix vieram para
nos ajudar
eles ajudam selecionar o melhor música
dentro uma quantidade de música absurda
como é que a gente escolheu o spotify
uma música um filme uma série de dentro
do netflix onde a gente não conseguiria
administrar e controlar escolha hoje uma
filme escolha um conteúdo né
então eles vieram com esse objetivo mas
obviamente tem que entender o que está
por trás disso né
por trás disso está uma caracterização
os algoritmos constroem uma
caracterização sobre a gente mas nada
sobre os dados que ele tem disponível
então quando isso acontece
imagine o seguinte está a gente a classe
utilizado aqui tá aí está o meu perfil
todo aberto pra vocês vendo as coisas
que eu mais gosto que eu menos gosto das
coisas que mais funciona pra mim que -
funcionam todas as minhas
características dos relacionados aos
meus dados estão aqui dentro
só que isso gerou um novo muro
afinal de contas eu me pareço com um
grupo dentro da internet dentro do mundo
de uma forma geral eu me pareço na
verdade com algumas pessoas e esta é uma
foto real das minhas redes está e esse
grupo não se relaciona com esse grupo
com esse grupo que nem com aquele isso
significa que as informações e os grupos
estão clusterizados porque que isso
acontece é simples
o algoritmo determina a partir de
determinadas informações
eu vou escolher baseada nas
características e clusters o que eu vou
mostrar quem determina isso é um homem à
máquina
é um homem porque toda regra precisa
partir de um ser humano
então quem programa para que isso
aconteça determina as regras é um ser
humano ea máquina executa com velocidade
precisão e provavelmente muito melhor do
que um ser humano
bom isso aqui é uma informação real
sobre o que aconteceu nas eleições
americanas
agora tá reparem na quantidade de
notícias falsas e as notícias
verdadeiras em preto e notem o que
aconteceu
o engajamento sobre notícias falsas foi
muito maior do que em casamento sobre
notícias verdadeiras
essa informação só mostra que isso aqui
sim pode ter manipulado o resultado de
eleição ou na verdade transformado o
resultado de uma eleição
capra vamos ver a todos os filtros então
afinal de contas todos esses filtros
estão gerando uma distorção da realidade
vamos lá como que é o que é a realidade
o que a sociedade como o que a realidade
da sociedade você sempre viveram em
comunidades em grupos estudaram em
escolas que deixe que construíram o seu
de vocês
e quando a gente vai construir como ser
já existiam regras elas não estavam tão
implícitas contentor ritmo mas ela já
existiam então fazer a é muito complexo
primeiro a gente tem que entender quando
vai pensar nisto está que por trás disso
tem uma imensidão de dados e que vocês
precisam saber como organizar essa
informação e é muito difícil porque
transformar um dado em algo que seja
útil em sabedoria prática tem um longo
caminho então a gente não está
normalmente preparada para fazer isso
tem algum atalho não tem um atalho que
eu posso dizer para vocês com certeza
que o mundo daqui pra frente vai ser
muito mais analítico e no mundo cada vez
mais analítico vão existir dois tipos de
ser humanos
um deles vai aprender configurar o que
quer receber vai aprender a dizer o que
ele quer ver vai aprender configurar um
algoritmo para mostrar as coisas que ele
quer ver que o outro não
o que vai acontecer com esses dois seres
humanos é que aquele que escolheu
configurar vai ver as coisas
informações que ele deseja ver aquele
que não escolheu configuram é vai ver as
coisas que um alguém escolheu o pv é o
caminho segundo a minha pergunta pra
vocês a vocês querem escolher as
informações
vocês estão o poder do que você recebe
do que você fique ministro do que vocês
têm informação é uma opção de vocês
obrigado
[Música]